on sait qu'une place sur st en fait une
famille on peut se découper
il s'appelle normand pedneault et vous
le voyez vous le constatez il est encore
vivement émotif quand il parle de ce qui
est arrivé il ya neuf ans quand même
isabelle richer il a été victime mais
est-il expliqué d'intimidation par
plusieurs travailleurs sur la côte-nord
toujours oui et au delà de l'émotion
véritable vous allez l'entendre
patrice qui avant ce récit ce qui est
particulièrement troublant dans ce que
monsieur peine nous raconte c'est que
ces lettres clique de rambo et de michel
bezeau qui au final en berne ils ont
obtenu ce qu'il cherchait c'est à dire
qu'ils ont chassé ces entrepreneurs du
saguenay qui faisait des travaux sur la
côte nord est qui refusait depuis
l'épisode que monsieur pernaut va
raconter ça se passe en novembre 2005 il
avait déjà travaillé sur la côte nord
avant il avait eu des ennuis mais bon il
avait cédé certaines exigences mais ça
coûte toujours plus cher on lit en rien
les travailleurs qui étaient pas
nécessairement qualifier alors cette
fois là il avait décidé de ne pas plier
d'amener ces travailleurs de faire les
travaux
michel bezeau l'avait prévenue que la
tempête sans viendrait elle est survenue
un jour où monsieur pedneault n'était
pas là mais c'est frère y était et c'est
eux qui y ont goûté et je pense que
c'est ça qui lui fait le plus mal c'est
d'entendre que ses frères ont souffert
on peut écouter une partie de son récit
par mes supérieurs à l'agora était dans
le coin et et puis des gens là mon frère
et moi c'est le point qui pose la face à
pestel fontaine qui est intoxiqué puis
l'émanation n'ont pas compris ce qu'on
est venu dire c'est gentil tu veut pas
nous écouter l'autre tu vas comprendre
de statut et la [ __ ] et mieux d'écouter
parce que la prochaine fois le tarot
pina rapide prophète pour susi quelle
place on sait que pour assurer des
enfants une famille pour s'occuper
oui et ça et c'est là où il a
particulièrement craqué quand on
menaçait sa famille
christian notre collègue avait fait tout
un reportage sur la terreur
qu'entretenait rimbaud ou la bosse sur
la côte-nord pour forcer
que les travailleurs uniquement les
travailleurs de la ftq de ceux de sa
gamme donc plus travailler là bas donc
c'est ce que la commission égrène sa
fête c'est le deuxième entrepreneurs là
oui effectivement le deuxième qui a
dénoncé d'ailleurs au ministre lessard
et lui a dénoncé par tous il ya dénoncé
aux représentants du ministère du
transport des transports du québec parce
que c'était quand même un contrat du mtq
bon de faire rapport il a dénoncé la
sûreté du québec il le fait des
dépositions
ça a pas donné de résultat et lors d'une
rencontre lasserre gtq à laquelle
monsieur lessard laurent lessard était
présent il a aussi parlé alors en
laissant il lui a raconté cet épisode là
sans grands résultats on peut écouter
à l'autre extrême lui avez-vous je pige
pas parler de ce problème mais au bout
j'ai vu cet événement lors de notre
directeur a brièvement raconté les
intimidations et cetera le brossage et s
est imposé de télévision j'avais passé
c'était quand même plusieurs gens
parlaient savais pas aussi sur lcn je
vaux mieux j'ai pas eu des fois que j'ai
pas eu d'écouté n'y a pas d'issue il n'y
a pas jugé bon d'élaborer sur le sujet
mais pas il faut dire qu'il ya quand
même monsieur lazhar qu'elle était
ministre du travail donc à déposer un
projet de loi qui essayaient de toucher
à cette zone là non il n'est pas le
premier il sera peut-être pas le dernier
effectivement c'est extrêmement
difficile de régenter cet aspect là est
d'ailleurs monsieur laissant se défend
toujours en disant je sais très bien
j'ai moi même été victime d'intimidation
quand j'ai abordé cette question là oui
bon je roule je vous repose la question
que j'ai posée hier oui
un bonheur qui se fasse poser quelques
questions et bien je pense que ça va
aller à la semaine prochaine parce que
le ça vaudrait pas la peine de le faire
venir juste pour jeudi alors qu'il
habite à sept-îles est ce qu'on aura
fini de son témoignage demain bref on
nous dit pas avant la semaine prochaine
très bien bon je repars nous avait
envoyé à voir